i am going to play for you now clips
from the most humiliating
deranged and disastrous interview that i
can ever remember donald trump giving
since the start of his political career
trump seems visibly scared in this
interview this interview took place last
night on fox news with sean hannity
after the news that new york was suing
trump and his family for 250 million and
seeking to prevent him from doing any
business in new york after
trump's own special master said you got
to cut the crap because these
explanations aren't cutting it and after
a judge determined that yes the
department of justice can now resume its
investigation of trump with the
documents they seized at mar-a-lago
trump is scared
and when trump gets scared he becomes
belligerent belligerent without even
drinking
let's get right into this trump missing
from fox news for a while allowed back
on
and before we even get into the criminal
stuff trump continuing this impossible
to understand statement that he both
completed the wall and was just about to
finish it when he left office came along
and they just dismantled that they
wouldn't finish the wall the wall was
completed the original section was
completed i said let's do more we did
more he could have that finished in
three weeks okay
the wall was done
but then they stopped it
but we had completed it
and then they said we could do it in
three weeks
i can't even make sense of that so i'm
not even going to try let's just
continue here is donald trump addressing
this issue
of the
values of his properties
see if you can make sense of this and
she said we're going to get him that her
whole campaign was based on that
and then she came after us we've been
going over this for years
and i actually thought because our
values are
really high the company is great i built
a great company like places like this so
many other places that i have
like this frankly i mean just the the
among the finest places anyway he can't
even address the substance just he gets
locked into this my places are great in
the world i actually thought that they
would never bring a case and she brought
it and the reason i thought because she
didn't have a case uh i was of the
impression she wanted to settle but i
had a problem because how do you pay
something
even if it's a small amount of money if
you're not guilty this was
he thought she was gonna just i mean
it's completely unintelligible folks
i thought we were just going to settle
with her instead but also how do you do
guilty when you didn't do anything wrong
but why were you expecting to settle
then but what are you talking about it
doesn't make any sense
this continues to just get worse and
worse trump unable to answer any
question directly asked by sean hannity
were you actually the one filling out
the loan applications
i don't think trump even answers that
question go back to leticia james did
you ever in your life fill out a loan
application running the trump
organization
well you know we make loans but i have
very little debt
well the question was do you fill out
the applications here's what i want to
tell you about
i might add one thing
they've demeaned me for years with this
stuff and now they find out i have very
little debt very he doesn't answer the
question okay the question was do you
fill out the loan apps and trump goes i
don't have much debt and you know we
make loans but who knows
here hannity actually seems to try to
help trump come up with possible legal
defenses
they're not great ideas i have to tell
you i was told that in your financial
statements when you make a loan
application you can confirm if you know
this or not know this do you put in a
caveat that actually says these are our
valuations because i don't know a
lending institution a bank a financial
institution that would lend money to
anybody and just go by the borrower's
estimation evaluation of a particular
property so if you're buying a 100
million dollar property and you're
putting x y and z up for leverage you
estimate its value with this they
estimate it at this right don't they
have a fiduciary responsibility before
you they give you that amount of money
so what they determine what the value is
first of all these are banks that have
the best law firms in the world the
biggest and best the most powerful they
do their own work they don't rely on us
but what they do
is we have a disclaimer and we put so
understand the subterfuge
whether or not that not that is true and
it is true generally speaking that
that's that banks do that
it doesn't make it any less fraudulent
for trump to put a bunch of this stuff
on paper in the way that he did as
outlined in the 200-page lawsuit
my people put it together i would
look at it and it looked fine but it's
not overly important what's important is
the property i have the best property
what happened sean is we have a
disclaimer right on the front
and it basically says you know get your
own people you're at your own risk this
was done by management it wasn't done by
it was done by management so don't rely
on the statement that you're getting
and it's and by the way it goes on for
like a page and a half it's a very big
disclaimer it's a very powerful
disclaimer super powerful guys it's
nobody's ever seen a disclaimer this
powerful to be to be completely honest
um trump then continues to argue
he
he's almost continuing to argue the
false real estate values that are at the
crux of the lawsuit he just keeps saying
these are the values after saying well
it's subjective so even if it's worth
less it's not really my problem now he
says well these are the values it's
ability to come up with their own
valuation because they've got their own
bosses and shareholders that they have
to answer to so they would look at a
property like this i don't even have a
mortgage on this property i don't have a
mortgage on most of my properties okay i
actually i want to address that for a
second
you and i might say
you either have a mortgage on a property
or you own it outright
in these
big commercial properties hotels and
resorts and this type of thing
saying i don't have a mortgage
versus i don't have debt are two
different things because in these types
of properties sometimes they are
financed with debt to equity financing
it's not a mortgage a mortgage is not
the instrument sometimes you would have
a commercial loan sometimes it's a
commercial construction loan because
you're buying a property for 50 million
and you need another 25 million for work
and so you need 75 million and you put
down 10
it's not a mortgage strictly speaking
they're not mortgages but it is still
debt and so that all of these little
statements
are
misdirections at their core you know i
used to read where i was overextended
and he had so much money borrowed and
i'm saying what are they talking about
but
and actually the one good thing is
people see what a great company i built
i built a great company a powerful
company you're getting sued for lying
and he's talking about his company a
company that's very lowly leveraged with
the among the best assets anywhere in
the world i mean you look at this asset
she has this down to 75 million dollars
i can tell you it's
many times that number she said oh he
valued it at 75 or whatever
she valued at 75. he doesn't even know
what he's saying this by the way
mar-a-lago what they're talking about is
mar-a-lago which leticia james believes
is worth 75 million and trump believes
is worth
worth 739
million does leticia james know but if i
were going i don't have a mortgage on
this forever if i was going to put a
mortgage on this property the
institutions are going to be coming over
they're going to go through comparable
properties all over palm beach or
whatever it is wherever it may be miami
we have them all over we have tremendous
properties so he's completely all over
the place then it starts to get almost a
little bit sad where trump admits he has
trouble referring himself to himself as
a former president
when they're here
we could do
lots of things we i think we had good
security we had as you know we had
tremendous secret service they are
unbelievable people
and they're all over mar-a-lago as
happens to a former president etc etc i
hate to use the word former because i
have a lot of problems with what
happened but the fact is you know we
wouldn't be having all these problems
that we have right now by the way with
ukraine and russia talking about nuclear
this has nothing to do with ukraine and
russia your weapons now i want to get to
all of that because what's happening in
the world is horrible
it's a it's a horrible thing what's
happening in the world at another point
during the interview trump again went
back to the fbi planted evidence at
mar-a-lago now that is old ground which
i thought he had gotten away from by
saying they didn't plant it it was
totally fine for me to have it but i
guess we're going back to maybe it was
planted when hillary broke them up broke
up all her phones with the hammers and
they did the bleach fit
oh god now the story is hillary with a
hammer smashing up trump's iphone all
the things that happened were incredible
well you could also say 33 million
documents or pages
with president obama that's very
questionable 33 million 33 000
happens to be a similar number 33
million
that's suspicious guys 33 a lot of 33
going on they're fighting over them or
arguing over them
the problem that you have is they go
into rooms they won't let anybody near
they wouldn't even let them in the same
building
did they drop anything into those piles
there it is there's the suggestion the
fbi could have dropped any of that stuff
which i by the way declassified why
would you declassify the very things the
fbi is planning to leave there
then maybe the whack the second wackiest
moment of this interview
trump says he can declassify documents
telepathically
by thinking about it
folks please stand it you know there's
different people say different things
but as i understand it doesn't have to
be if you're the president of the united
states you can declassify just by saying
it's declassified even by thinking about
it right because you're sending it
to mar-a-lago or to wherever you're
sending it and
there doesn't have to be a process there
can be a process but there doesn't have
to be so
trump can telepathically declassify
documents
but he didn't take them they might have
been planted by the fbi and it just so
happened that they had been
telepathically declassified by donald
trump
here is the final moment from this
interview
and
it is so
unintelligible trump is on a word salad
that is so unintelligible that about a
minute in hannity
tries to
stop trump to help him
because what he's saying is making so
little sense
and even hannity can't save trump so let
me ask you this question because i i
think this is the next logical question
because the president of the united
states you unlike say hillary clinton in
her case right a president has the power
to declassify correct okay you had said
on truth social a number of times you
didn't declare
okay
is there a process what was your process
to deal with it doesn't have to be a
process as i understand it that you know
there's different people say different
things but as i understand that doesn't
have to be if you're the president of
the united states you can declassify
just by saying it's declassified even by
thinking about it because you're sending
it
to mar-a-lago or to wherever you're
sending it and
there doesn't have to be a process there
can be a process but there doesn't have
to be right so that's what we saw before
and now it goes off the rails and within
30 seconds hannity tries to help and
even he can't save trump does it you
make that decision so when you send it
it's declassified we
i declassified everything now i
declassify things and we were having a
lot of problems with nara you know nara
is a radical left group of people
running that thing and when you send
documents over there
i would say there's a very good chance
that a lot of those documents will never
be seen again there's also a lot of
speculation because of what they did the
severity of the fbi you're coming in
raiding
mar-a-lago
were they looking for the hillary
clinton emails that were deleted but
they are around some place were they
looking for the response
no no they may be saying they may have
thought that it was in there okay and a
lot of people said the only thing is
trump saying
the fbi might have thought
hillary's bleached emails
were at mar-a-lago i i can't tell you
what he's saying it would give the kind
of severity that they showed by actually
coming in and raiding with many many
people
is
the hillary clinton
deal the russia russia russia stuff or
i mean there are there are a number of
things the spying on trump's campaign
folks this guy is scared in a way i've
never seen him be scared
i think that's the explanation here the
behavior the delusions the unhinged
nature there is something materially
different here
and i believe it's that trump is scared
out of his wits let me know we will have
this clip on our facebook page we will
have it on our instagram i want to hear
from you
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent
deep sleep is lowering your core body
temperature when your body stays cooler
at night you're more comfortable and
your sleep is better our sponsor sleep
me is the home of chili sleep the
customizable climate controlled sleep
solutions that can improve your sleep by
keeping you cooler at night there are
three different chili sleep systems
there's the uhler the cube and the new
doc pro with double the cooling power
all three systems are water-based
temperature controlled mattress toppers
that fit over your existing mattress to
provide you with your ideal sleep
temperature you can go as cool as 55
degrees you can go really hot if you
want i keep mine at 60 beautiful
temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great i didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than i already
did go to sleep dot me slash pacman to
learn more and get 25 off your new chili
sleep system click the link below to
start staying cool at night